bonsoir à tous le préfet de la région
corse a été assassiné de plusieurs
balles dans la tête ce soir ajaccio par
deux inconnus il était un peu plus de
21h et claude erignac a été abattu en
pleine rue alors qu'il sortait de sa
voiture c'est la première fois qu'un
haut fonctionnaire de l'état est
assassiné en corse les faits william
irigoyen
c'est à 21h15 que claude erignac a
trouvé la mort le préfet de la région
corse a été assassiné devant le complexe
de loisirs du kallisté en plein centre
d'ajaccio claude erignac se rendait avec
son épouse à un concert il venait de
descendre de sa voiture lorsque deux
personnes peut être plus se sont
précipités sur lui ils ont tiré
plusieurs coups de feu dans le dos de
claude herring les services de police
aurait retrouvé un pistolet à proximité
du lieu de l'assassinât on ne connaît
pas pour l'heure le calibre de l'armé
utilisée âgé de 60 ans claude erignac
avait été nommé préfet de corse en
janvier 96
cet assassinat intervient deux semaines
après l'annoncé par le flnc canal
historique de la fin de la trêve des
attentats mais pour le moment rien ne
permet d'affirmer qu'il s'agit là d'un
assassinat politique claude erignac est
le premier haut fonctionnaire de l'état
assassiné dans l'île
et le président